hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and uh
i'm just checking in on you i'm just
checking in on you see now
hopefully your work week's going i know
a lot of people are working from home
during this new normal
the new normal jesus [ __ ] christ i
will never
understand you know all
somebody somebody says it and then
everybody else just
that's the thing to say i want to say
that you know is it to do normal
why can't somebody switch it up and just
say well you know the way [ __ ] is now
that scares people don't use profanity
you have to say the new normal
if they just hear the word normal
they're going to feel more normal
i heard some scary [ __ ] you know
was on twitter but jesus so who the [ __ ]
knows if it's true or not but
we're saying by 2050 over a billion
people are going to be displaced
due to global warming and uh
i i just don't understand these [ __ ]
these [ __ ] people in power man they
just keep it's like a big circle jerk
they just keep [ __ ] blowing each
other
trying to make more money and [ __ ]
over regular people and i just don't
know where they think
they just think like ah what's gonna
happen after i die it's like you don't
give a [ __ ] about your kids
it's unbelievable so um
you got to pick that sweet spot the
sweet longitude latitude
to buy your safety house you know far
enough from the equator
for far you know far enough inland from
the ocean
but not too north to the polar ice caps
if you can figure out where that place
is
right all the while
like in the back of your head if you did
pick the right place then you're
gonna gonna be one of the last few
to survive and then you're gonna have to
go through that
right and i'll tell you what'll be what
would be [ __ ] great
is all these [ __ ] goddamn red states
for the for
the longest time have been [ __ ] on
hollywood saying we're all in a
pedophile ring and all that you wait
till we're gone
red states then what are you gonna
[ __ ] watch
huh who do you think produced that
[ __ ]
duck hunter show you used to watch that
was us
the bleeding heart blue ties um
[Laughter]
the wild redneck television they'll have
it they'll they'll figure it out they'll
do something they'll
stick a generator up to a [ __ ]
satellite dish they'll figure out how to
do it
i got to switch it up here i'm always
[ __ ] on [ __ ] liberal states i got
to start [ __ ] on the redneck states
now i just got to do it
i gotta do it um speaking of redneck i
found
one of those [ __ ] gmc uh motorhomes
that i love
i found i found a [ __ ] nice one but
you know
my wife hit me between the eyes with
logic
she's like it looks like [ __ ] i go yeah
but the body's straight
i got a guy he can fix the whole thing
up and all she's like how much is that
going to cost
like well you know quite a bit she go
i go yeah but once i have that i can i
can do [ __ ] road gigs in it it'll pay
for itself i can do road gigs in this
just listen to me
i can do road gigs in this thing i can
we can finally go up to yellowstone i
can take you out to joshua tree and all
that and she just starts laughing at me
i go what she goes why don't we just
rent one
or why don't we just get a new one if
it's going to cost that much because
it's not going to be as cool
as stepping out of the [ __ ] ron
burgundy mobile
come on you like vintage fashion why
can't i go out and buy a vintage [ __ ]
rv
oh it's unreal i am so [ __ ]
tempted to just buy that
and it's a jalopy i'm not i'm not
[ __ ] kidding this thing is a [ __ ]
hooptie needs a lot of love and care i'm
so tempted to just buy this [ __ ]
thing
have it redone and then just one day you
pull up when it's shiny
shiny and new it was exciting and new
come aboard ron burgundy's [ __ ] you
on that green bed right
if i just pull up in that [ __ ] thing
well i mean you know i mean how mad can
she be let's go let's go to joshua tree
whoa right
right just take it down the street you
know in a perfect world that works out
in the real world her bottom lip starts
quivering and she starts crying
what else are you doing that i don't
know about
and runs back into the house you know
and then the awful sound of me shut
killing the engine
neighbors looking out i don't know what
happened
he pulled up in that big green truck and
i don't know she started crying
are they getting divorced is that his
new house
um anyway whatever a man can dream kenny
a man can dream a man can dream speaking
of dreams
guess whose dream [ __ ] ended your
vegas [ __ ]
knights good lord dallas wins the first
game vegas wins game number two you
think it's going to be a nice little
back and forth
and then dallas gives them the yellow
right there fred
pow right the old [ __ ] kisser bang
bang
bang ran the table
ran the [ __ ] table they never got the
ball back that was it they ran the clock
just ran the [ __ ] table
congratulations
dallas texas two things number one you
have a hockey team
number two number two
they are in the stanley cup final
stanley cup it looks like a giant shot
glass it's as shiny as the spurs on your
[ __ ]
horse it's as shiny as the truck you
drive that's never seen
mud that's what i've seen out there i've
seen some of the cleanest cowboys i've
ever seen in my life in texas you know
you got the real ones that live in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere
celebrating hitler's birthday and doing
some cowboy [ __ ] right
finding their last little calf by
looking up at the stars whatever it is
those [ __ ] people do
right walking around with their assless
chaps
you know and then you got the fake ones
the ones who live in the cities you know
where they have the four-door with an
extra cab the [ __ ] bed is like
two feet long by the time they're done
with it it's a goddamn living room in
there
these shiniest [ __ ] trucks i've never
seen so many pickup trucks in my [ __ ]
life
that have never seen a day of work
shinier than my truck
and i i don't do any work in it
anyway you have a hockey team and
they're in the stanley cup final is it
the finals or is it the final i don't
know what it is
but i say anyways so i call them the
finals
um and they are waiting for the winner
of the tampa bay
lightning versus the uh
long island not long island new york
islanders
i guess the island has won the last game
i missed the last game
huge win for the islanders 2-1 makes a
series
3-2 you know a little bit of pressure
now on
tampa bay um i was too busy watching
um i was too busy watching
[ __ ] uh that amazing
amazing amazing [ __ ] amazing game
celtics first miami heat even though we
lost i mean what a [ __ ] block that
was a
block for the ages all [ __ ] ball
against one of the rising stars of the
nba i don't know [ __ ] about hoop i just
know a good game when i see one and i
also got a big
i hated seeing the clippers lose because
all the laker fans out here were
[ __ ] themselves when they're up
three games to one they were legit
nervous and then the second they lose
they all start trashing them including
magic johnson
magic johnson was sweating the la
clippers
you know the fact that he had to go out
and go tweet something i was like oh my
god magic johnson was scared
um yeah they were looking like world
beaters they were looking like the
strongest team in the east and what the
[ __ ]
happened gee it was like it was a lid on
the goddamn basket i watched that whole
game
and i can't i watched the second half of
that game what am i talking about
i think i was the jinx i didn't know
what happens like the clippers were up
by like [ __ ] eight and the next thing
you know they were down by eight
and then uh paul george and leonard
couldn't [ __ ] hit a shot to save
their lives what a game to go cold in
and then all of these losers
you know who've never even had to sink a
big putt in a [ __ ] uh
one of those little putt and green
things what do you call those things uh
magic golf miniature golf you know
haven't even hit a big putt there is
just sitting there trashing all of these
[ __ ] guys that could dunk on you and
your entire family
you know and then take the family
portrait off the wall and smash it over
your head
you know we all have bad days they had a
bad day my condolences to them
congratulations to the denver nuggets
i'm pulling for you guys you got to do
it you have to root against the [ __ ]
lakers
the the whole the whole [ __ ] legacy
is oh this is this is where all the
great centers
have played yeah but you never draft you
drafted george mike and you drafted some
seven foot guy from a ymca in 1940
other than that none of them are yours
chamberlain
abdul jabar shaquille o'neal
lebron james none of them
none of them goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i think they're gonna buy another
one
tell you the celtics got to get better
at buying championships
we got to get better at it man we got to
figure out a [ __ ] way
you know i don't know maybe with global
warming you know la will be too [ __ ]
hot and on fire for anybody to play and
then all of a sudden we'll have like la
weather in boston
you know then hollywood will move out
there and then all the [ __ ] hot ass
will move out there and then we can
start getting the top-tiered [ __ ]
people around the league you know i
don't know who the [ __ ] knows what but i
think the lakers got a great chance of
win i'm just [ __ ] around you know i'm
a celtics fan i [ __ ] hate the lakers
i respect
i respect the lakers okay
i respect it okay they're out here in
hollywood they got uh they got a bunch
of [ __ ] for everybody to bang after
the game they got great weather and then
they use that to
their advantage it's basically what it
is god bless em
we have to somehow make s uh going
snowmobiling and ice fishing
cool to seven foot black guys
[Laughter]
you know i don't know um anyway
uh but the celtics are still in it uh
this is gonna be a great series
um i don't give a [ __ ] obviously i want
the celtics to win i just don't want the
lakers to win
i don't i just don't want to because
then they're going to be tied with us
with championships
and i'm gonna have to listen to all
these [ __ ] morons giving me [ __ ] out
here
who don't know anything about hoop as
long as it's an old school laker fan
then i actually really enjoy talking to
but most of them are just like
ah celtics are [ __ ] great talk
um anyway uh plowing ahead here let's
talk nfl football
[Music]
um the patriots have seattle cam newton
against russell wilson um
i don't know these are like two teams of
transition right now i don't know what's
going on with seattle
and i'm hoping that we're going to build
off that win cam gets a little more
comfortable
the receivers get a little more open and
maybe he doesn't have to run for 75
yards i'm i'm
i'm liking our offensive line continue
to protect
cam newton and uh we will see what
happened um
tonight thursday night match up
who do you got you got joe burrow versus
baker mayfield the city daddy bagley
baby babe um
i heard joe burrow had a great game last
week and they kind of got [ __ ] by some
call
at the end i didn't see either one of uh
i didn't see their game i didn't see the
browns games but uh
i don't know i like both of those guys
and uh so i'm hoping that's gonna be a
good game
and then the tom brady buccaneers the
tampa bay bucket is excuse me
have the panthers and teddy bridgewater
one of the great names in sport oh today
bridgewater teddy black magic um
remember that
sexy beast that was it teddy
teddy bass i can't remember mr black
magic
um i hope this plane crashes um
anyway i'm looking forward to all of
that [ __ ] there's like so much [ __ ]
sports going on right now and i've
been uh really busy getting ready to uh
do my little stand-up tour
coming up that i am very excited about
um
i got a couple of spots this week i've
gotten back into the groove man
i've been riffing new [ __ ] is coming out
i'm enjoying
uh all of that stuff and uh hopefully
you know it all comes together and then
by the time i go out to the
farmland out there in connecticut
you know i could possibly uh have some
good shows that's what i'm hoping for
you know you can only hope
that's all you can do you can just kind
of hope um
so anyways we're coming down to it
everybody i think you know uh
i don't know what we're coming down to i
haven't even looked at the covid numbers
i just feel like you know
as they gradually put the fire out out
here
so [ __ ] state's on fire um
covered numbers by
state by stat oops
let's see here
april yeah we would we had nothing and
then we went up then we peaked
now oh we're going down we're going down
down down this is good man we're going
down i like it
let's see here uh there's been 771 000
cases
14 000 648 deaths
um 255 000 in los angeles county
what the [ __ ] 6200 died
riverside at 55 oh this must be 771 000
cases
in california oh okay it said united
states here people why do you listen to
this podcast
um wow man there's been a lot of [ __ ]
people caught this [ __ ] not too many
died six seven
eight nine about 10 000 people died
three you know what have we got
close to a million cases it's still a
lot of [ __ ] people huh
um i don't know is it going in the right
direction
did you see those [ __ ] idiots talking
about masks that one lady's like
you know what i gotta wear a mask i mean
george floyd said
uh you know i can't breathe he died
and now now we're saying we can't
breathe and they're saying put on a mask
it's just like oh sweetheart
what happened uh you didn't get the good
books
um i really just think that that is j
it's really
just you know the news media you got to
have a heart every once in a while when
you just get a [ __ ] dope on to just
you know keep the footage for yourselves
to laugh
why would you put that out there you
know
then they have this other one this
[ __ ] sweet old lady she's like you
know who likes mass
child molesters
oh grandma go make some cookies
please please go make some cookies you
know i didn't get mad at the grandmother
you know what i mean it's just
your grandparents say crazy [ __ ] that's
their job their job
is to spoil you make cookies and you
just you just
never bring up politics religion
race relations because all you'll be
like what the [ __ ]
just came out of that person's mouth all
of that norman rockwell look about him
it just it just goes away it goes away
um so anyway
why won't you let me get this [ __ ] rv
you know what she's right it's [ __ ]
stupid what am i thinking
where am i gonna keep it i'm probably
gonna use it like three weeks out of the
year
and then i have a bus sitting out in
front of my [ __ ] house like what am i
what am i supposed to do with that thing
oh man it'd be fun i wonder if i can
just rent one that would be great
who's gonna rent me their [ __ ]
you know i really [ __ ] hate when i do
that
every time i try to see how much time is
left on this podcast i get like if not
every time 50
of the time end up hitting stop now i
gotta splice these goddamn things
together people you know there's no
production value
there is no production value
on this podcast one of these days i'm
going to get a studio
right i'm going to get a studio and
there's going to be somebody i talk to
and there's going to be sound effects
i'm going to [ __ ] do this up
but until then if you guys could just
bear with me
um all right all form like we do a
couple of reads here all
form all right if you've been listening
to this show for a while
you've probably heard me talk about my
helix mattress
very quick helix endorsement these guys
make okay helix has left
the bedroom and started making sofas
they just launched a new company called
all form and they're already making the
best sofas we've ever seen
so basically they make a custom mattress
for you to sleep and nap on
right uh napping is just a
short sleep for people new to this
planet all right
um and now i guess they're gonna make a
a couch
that forfeits to your body
jesus christ you'll be nodding off all
day so what makes an all-form
sofa really cool for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize a sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost
of traditional stores you can pick your
fabric
and it's spill stain and scratch
resistant
so just imagine the things you can do on
this couch
um the sofa color the color of the legs
sofa size and shape to make sure it's
perfect for you and your home that's
great
uh they got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to eight-seat sectionals
if when you want to have an orgy
and have no evidence of it afterwards
evidently so there's something for
everyone
and you can always start small and buy
more
seats later if you want um
later on and buy more seats later on
if you want your all form sulfur to grow
and change with you
when you move all form sulfurs are also
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa it could take weeks or even months
to arrive
and you would need someone to come and
assemble it in your home
all form just takes three to seven days
oh my god to arrive in the mail
what the [ __ ] are they doing over there
yeah can i get a green couch right
yeah no problem okay we'll have a
tantric get your stuff your [ __ ] ass
freak out
just immediately just start assembling
it they probably have like all the
couches all [ __ ] ready
and people just sitting there you know
just like twitching ready to grab some
fabric
um i have an all-form leather couch for
my office it looks really fancy but it's
also comfortable
and if getting a sofa they don't need me
to say this they're gonna you can
have a [ __ ] couch whatever color you
want whatever size you want
delivered right to your house in three
to seven days you can't beat that
uh and if getting a sofa without trying
it in a store sounds a little risky
don't worry you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep it
that's more than three months and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free
gross and give you a full refund
dude you could shoot 300 days of [ __ ]
oh 100 days of pornos on that thing and
send it right back imagine that
without a [ __ ] stain on it they even
offer a forever warranty
literally forever a forever warranty
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
f o a-l-l-f-o-r m dot com slash burr and
all form is offering twenty percent off
all
orders for our listeners at all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m
dot com slash burr a forever warranty
good lord whatever color you want
it's beautiful beautiful oh look who's
back in don't cheeto
um finding clothes that fit
you just right can be
incredibly challenging talk about how
you feel when you find clothing that
fits
you just right well i like to feel like
i'm in shape you know
you know when you start putting on
pounds you just you know subconsciously
start pulling your shirt away from your
your uh your your belly and your man
tits
you know you do that um i hate having to
do that all right indochinos
suits are great for weddings and work
and they even offer casual options
like shirts coats and chinos
indochino you can get custom filled
custom filled custom fitted suits coats
and casual we're
uh at surprisingly affordable prices
[Music]
uh customize everything from the fabric
and the lining to the lapel shape and
monogram
and since your order is made to your
exact measurements
it always fits you perfectly yeah
provided you don't pig out or go puke
behind a dumpster until it comes
uh if you're getting married indochino
is a no-brainer for you and your
groomsmen
forget off the rack and they don't fit
different body types indochino gives
everything everyone
a tailored fit order with ease and get
it shipped fast no matter where you live
and
with all the ways to customize you can
add a personal touch
everyone will be proud to wear without
emptying their pockets the best part
indochino suits start at 299
with all customize our customizations
included
call to action this section is mandatory
if you don't read this you will not get
paid uh visit one of the indochino
showrooms across north america
or book a virtual appointment and shop
online at indochino.com
and right now you'll get to get 30 bucks
off any purchase of 3.99 or more when
you
enter the code bur burr at checkout
that's indochino i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code bur b-u-r-r
and lastly but certainly
certainly not leastly
certainly not kenny easley sorry
remember him
how about big shoulder pads used to be
what a [ __ ] was he was a safety right
uh simply say all right here's the thing
about home security companies most trap
you with high
prices tricky contracts and lousy
customer support
so while there are a lot of options out
there there's only one no brainer
simply safe simply safe's got everything
you need to protect your home with none
of the drawbacks of traditional home
security
it's got an arsenal of sensors and
cameras to blanket every room
window and door tailored specifically
for your home professional monitoring
keeps watch
day and night ready to send police fire
or medical professional professionals if
there's an emergency
you can set it up yourself in under an
hour just peel and stick the sensors
exactly where you need them
no techn technician required and there's
no contract no pushy sales guys no
hidden fees no fine print all this
starts at just 15 bucks a month
i'm not the only one who thinks simply
safe is great u.s news and world report
named it the best
overall home security of 20 20
20 20 20. um
try simply save today at simply say
bird.com you get a free hd security
camera
there's nothing to lose that's
simplysafebird.com
there you go look at that you can get a
[ __ ] sofa
that's customized for you and your
[ __ ] thick thighs
then you can get a suit that's exactly
what you wanted
right to your size you know you got a
big belly some man tits and long arms
they'll make a jacket that fits and then
if you don't want anybody to steal it
you don't want your doppelganger to come
into your house take your comfortable
sofa and holy
[ __ ] does that jacket fit i think it
does you get the simply safe
and you got an hd camera to see exactly
what that [ __ ] looks like
right when the mancherian candidate
version of you [ __ ] shows up
could you kill your doppelganger would
that be [ __ ] weird do you think it'd
be easier to kill somebody who doesn't
look like you
or somebody who kind of reminds you of
you i guess that would all depend on
whether you hated yourself or not
you know then you get busted of course
because you didn't plan it out
and the cops ask you is this sweating
you you know and you're like all right
all right i did it i did it i go well
why did you do it it's just like well
you know what to be honest with you i
hate myself
and i just didn't have the balls to kill
myself
because it's against my religion so i
killed this person that uh seemed
reasonably happy
but sort of looked like me from a
distance
mr bird you need glasses uh yes yes i do
well i want to let you know that that
person was strawberry blonde
okay they were not a redhead oh
oh sorry about that well we're sorry too
book em um anyway
so the [ __ ] am i i just out of people i
have nothing to talk about i have
nothing going on in my [ __ ] life i am
either working my ass off or just
sitting in my [ __ ] house
i've started production on a couple of
things through uh all things comedy
i've been working on those things those
things are exciting but i can't talk
about them
i can't talk about them therefore i
cannot fill up the last three minutes of
this [ __ ] podcast
so evidently this is just gonna become a
[ __ ] staring contest
um no now you know some i got to be
honest with you the way you guys [ __ ]
raked me over the coals deservedly
[ __ ] get this goddamn cord over here
deservedly raked me over the [ __ ]
coals
for repeating that story about trump i
am now afraid
to do any stories about politics which
is probably a good thing i'll get the
[ __ ] out of that
i'll try to stay away from that because
i know how sensitive people are
they take that [ __ ] seriously as i was
just sitting there talking about killing
your doppelganger because you didn't
have the balls to kill yourself
all of that is [ __ ] fine but don't be
[ __ ] talking about actual goddamn
people don't talk
about some liberal woman who wants to
run for [ __ ] office and then don't
talk about the square
job [ __ ] whether there's not even
is there even a woman republican
holding office i mean those people are
just so [ __ ] sexist
i'm [ __ ] with you just waiting for
actually geraldine [ __ ] ferrara was a
republican
let me see let me see here women
republicans
all right here we go images of women
women in the gop
oh the grand old [ __ ] oh isn't that
cool you know
right women have played a key role in
the republican party since its
establishment in 1854.
i would love to read that first line at
an all woman's college
just get an applause break good night um
the republican party and republican
women were the primary
forces behind women's suffrage movement
and the passage oh yeah i remember that
yeah
because they both switched one used to
be liberal and then the other became
conservative like i don't understand how
the [ __ ] that happened
so then what republicans like to do um
you know the people
against slavery in the 1800s were
actually republicans
and it's like they flip-flopped you know
what i mean i don't know
i think that's what happened all right
read more all i know is every woman that
they have in the gop
is a black and white photo looks like
it's my first stand-up headshot
now women ladies
clambake uh women
republicans
cans in office
women serving in the 116th congress now
i want to know who's
more republican women are running for
office than ever women in the united
states house of representatives here we
go
come on low number low number
uh nancy pelosi i didn't know she was a
republican
oh this is just women right nancy pelosi
became the first
female house minority whip
in 2002 jesus that's none of that
sounded good
minority whip all in the same thing like
she went on to become the first and only
to date
female speaker of the united states
she's a lesbian she's dating the speaker
of the united
also in 2007 maisie
hirono entered the u.s house
representative as the first
female buddhist in either chamber of
commerce
congress in 2011 the u.s house of
representatives got its first woman
bathroom
near the chamber
what do you mean a woman's bathroom
i've never understood that [ __ ] it's
like you know you got it
once you have a [ __ ] in there anybody
can use it right
well they just have a stand-up [ __ ]
like a piss trough
picturing tip o'neill dropping his pants
taking a dump in that i you would think
that they'd have a toilet for the guys
these people are [ __ ] weird man
politics is weird this is why i don't
pay attention to this [ __ ]
um all right anyways this has been the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast um
i got to say god bless all of these
firefighters out here in california
saving our asses again this year and uh
you know i really hope that there's more
people
uh i don't know that there's just a way
smaller companies that give a [ __ ] about
the environment can start making stuff
for everybody
and we can actually buy stuff off of
them and then they won't sell
out to those [ __ ] on shark tank those
types of people that don't give a [ __ ]
evidently about anything
uh my wife loves watching that show
you know i hate that she's just watching
people in a position of power
taking advantage of people hey you got a
great idea here's the deal i'll give you
the money that you need
i'm gonna own 99 of your company and you
can go [ __ ] yourself how about that
uh we were thinking maybe like 50 50.
all right i'm out
and i like when they give an offer
and then the people don't accept it and
then the sharks they act like a bunch of
babies
you know because they didn't get their
way and i know it's just a [ __ ] tv
show but
um that is how business is done
oh that's a great idea i will buy that
from you so you can get a nicer
two-bedroom apartment and then i will
my me and my company will get all the
credit for your [ __ ] idea
what was the last time there was an
inventor that you knew their name let me
see famous inventors
inventors inventors
in
2000s let's see here if there's anything
10 things you didn't realize were
invented see they don't they'd skip
right past it 10 things you didn't
realize it
list of inventors all right here we go
all right this guy these are the birth
dates 1906
1840 1879 1914
1901 1916 1960
randy randy
because it's with an i randy meow al
shushi chewie invented the disposable
cell phone
you know yeah looking out for drug
dealers good for him 1928
1989. ruth
amos invented stair steady the [ __ ] is
that
uh mary mary 1866
mary anderson invented the windshield
wiper blade there you go
momofuku ando
get the [ __ ] out of here momofuku's one
of my favorite [ __ ] places in new
york to get something to eat
they got those big [ __ ]
bowls uh noodles and all of that [ __ ]
asian uh
style and uh this guy momofuku ando
invented instant noodles
lived a nice long life too 97 years
hal anger
he invented the gamma camera
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is
all right why don't we just see what
they invented then i'll read the person
single curtain focal plan shutter
oh jesus christ imagine a conversation
with that person
i notice you have curtains i don't want
to brag
[Laughter]
let me try oh here we go look at this
piece of [ __ ]
1788 to 1874.
neil arnott from the united kingdom
invented the waterbed you
[ __ ] [ __ ] dirty old man
um come on there's gotta be something
good in here
sawmill circular saw
video game console german-born american
ralph h
bayer look at the germans trying to get
credit i mean german-born
american oh he's born in germany he
comes over all right all right
whatever whatever we'll take 50 on that
one
uh come on the color tv
john logey baird scotland
that's right he was sick all those
gingers looking [ __ ] awful in black
and white
um let's get one more here
oh frederick banting canada
invented insulin
alexander graham bell invented the
telephone didn't he steal all this [ __ ]
from tesla or is that just some [ __ ]
[ __ ]
uh ballpoint pen the cheese slicer
flash freezing the stereo
the uk allen blue mine
seat belt sweden came up with the seat
belt no wonder volvos are so safe
the taxi meter germany of course
once he went 7.6 kilometers
uh
come on give me something the lawnmower
we'll close on this
edwin beard budding england you know i
always assume
that most [ __ ] was invented in america
you know i don't know why
look at all this [ __ ] uh electron
cooling
russia the bull engine or a modified
steam engine england
bunsen bunsen burner germany
horseshoe machine first usable iron
railroad spike
scotland the world wide web
was not al gore it was robert kellough
belgium stock ticker tape
that was the u.s yeah you want a [ __ ]
parade with some lies on it yeah we got
you
uh induction coil ireland quick release
skewer
italy all right this is just
who gives a [ __ ] stuff here tension
spoke
wheels artificial cell
chapman stick that's a chapstick
people how do i get out i'm going down a
[ __ ] rabbit hole there's like a
million things here neon lamp dishwasher
you [ __ ] [ __ ] josephine
cochrane
you [ __ ] [ __ ] the the goddamn
dishwasher is the biggest lie of the
20th century
the [ __ ] thing never worked it never
[ __ ] worked i used to do a bit about
that gut i used to a bit about that guy
i don't know who the [ __ ] invented it
oh my god i remember i used to do that
bit
whoever invented it was in a toxic
relationship because they would get
nagged the entire [ __ ] time because
the goddamn thing doesn't work
it doesn't wash the dishes it makes them
wet it dries them
it's great at drying them it makes them
wet and then it dries them and then it
just bakes on whatever the [ __ ] you cook
there
all right this has been a little extra
long podcast i gotta get off the phone
go [ __ ] yourself i gotta go get on the
phone is what i have to do i gotta get
off the podcast
enjoy the music from the great andrew
themillis and i will get
back to you on monday go pats uh i'm
rooting for joe burrow
i am rooting for the texans against the
ravens
um i always got to go underdogs here and
uh what else
and i'm rooting for tom brady against
carolina that's it
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and i'll
talk to you on monday please enjoy my
segment on the sports gambling podcast
with sean green
and ryan crema coming up after the music
bill burr on the sports gaming podcast
is brought to you by mybookie.ag
head over to mybookie.ed to get in on
all the nfl action and use the promo
code bur
for a 100 deposit bonus that's my
bookie.ag promo code burr
joining us on the line comedian patriots
fan bill burr
bill pat started 1-0 in the cam newton
era
how exciting was that um
you know it was it was definitely i was
happy that we got the win the dolphins
always play as difficult
always plays tough i mean um i was
excited
the about our offensive line looked good
i still saw
you know some of the problems we had
from last year slightly improved but
it's early on
you know i have faith in bill belichick
cam newton looked great
um i'm not too excited that he was our
top rusher
yeah you know 75 yards i mean i'm kind
of old school with that where
i just feel like you're gonna get hurt
so hopefully uh
you know sony michelle will you know
pick it up yards for us and he can stand
in the pocket and guys like harry can
maybe step up or something like that
you look like a viable number two
receiver and i thought i thought our
defense looked pretty good
you don't strike me as a jersey guy but
uh if you were to get a cam newton
jersey are you waiting until he
until he wins a certain number of games
till he hits a certain threshold
yeah dude i i haven't bought a jersey
since i was like a kid
i mean i maybe got like a a steve grogan
one i think was the last one i had
that's probably a badass throwback one
now well
it wasn't the mitchell and ness version
of it it was the hermann sporting goods
version so um
no no i'm all in with cam cam's our guy
and you know the guy is an amazing
uh quarterback he's got incredible arm
field vision and all of that type of
stuff they just got you just gotta have
more than one week
to get on the same page now the other
the other big game we talked about last
week
brady and the uh bucks went down to new
orleans
didn't get it for two of my bets oh and
two against the spread but your team won
so you kind of hedged yourself
there brady looked good early he had
that he had that drive he had the uh
rushing touchdown
it seemed like things were going well
and then it just kind of unraveled for
tampa bay
yeah i mean i wouldn't put that on him i
mean it was a couple times he thought a
guy was going to keep running and he
stops
you know he did have the pick six but i
mean that happens it just happens it's
it's it's week one
i thought but what i saw that was great
as a fan but upsetting
because i'm because he's not on the
patriots anymore still has the same zip
still has the same fire
the leadership and all of that i mean
um i think tampa bay is going to be a
problem for people
well now the bucks they're at home
they're laying nine points against the
carolina panthers
what do you think what do you think
about the bounce back game for uh tom
brady in the bucks i think this is going
to be a nice week for them to go out and
score some points
get some sports writers on their side i
just think
i think they're going to have a great
game uh you know the 11 000 people that
are allowed to go to the stadium will be
excited to see tom
and uh you know we shall see
it is it is funny how they gronkowski
back out there too
yeah it was good to see him catch a
couple passes didn't do anything o.j
howard got the touchdown
nfl is better with gronk in it that's
all and and gronk in tampa is also
probably good for things so i'm i'm
happy with the situation
i'm a little sad i'm a little sad they
got up to the loss because now everyone
gets to
start chirping about belichick versus
brady which we don't need right now but
uh you know i don't know sean i knew
that was gonna happen i know but now now
that now it's what
it's on the t it's on the t and now
people are hitting it so hopefully brady
comes back with a vengeance yeah i mean
against that people could just not pay
attention to that crap i just
i think so much of that stuff just it's
a symptom of 24 hours
of media and then there's also like just
um
you know that's just how they sell every
show this person versus that person
this candidate versus that candidate
this country versus that country so
red versus blue uh yeah the big ten
they're coming back and it was and we
kind of hit on this last week talking
about the where they draw the lines for
uh college football it seems to be
political like
all these southern republican states
they were all in on football early
then these swing states in the big ten
they were not doing it and now they are
doing football
and then the the super left blue states
are holding out no football maybe it'll
be later on
it's just hilarious how it's falling
right on party lines again
yeah well you know i mean they make the
school so much money
oh god nobody's gonna show up to watch
the math team
solve problems so i mean that's what it
is and uh
you know i mean i think it's easier for
you know some of the
obviously the ivy league and stuff like
that i mean they get probably more money
from uh
you know eggheads that used to go there
giving them money whatever however the
hell that works out there but
um yeah the football team isn't carrying
harvard's endowment
it's gonna be all the rocket scientists
kicking back money
yeah but i mean if a hundred thousand
people were showing up every week to see
harvard play yale
then they would be playing too i mean at
the end of the day
they got to make their money big a big
thursday night game bangles
at browns where are you at with uh baker
mayfield and and what'd you say
isn't it bengals but there's like three
different pronunciations
i don't know how you just said it
everybody says he says bangles like the
girl band
yeah it's it's bengals oh you know this
is how dumb i am i didn't realize there
was a difference between the girl band
and the football team i assumed they
were the same they're all the bangles
yeah they're all the best don't
disrespect the band with how the bengals
have played the last few years
oh man that was a heartbreaking loss for
bengals fans
everywhere that offensive pi to kind of
uh
cost him the game and then the kicker
comes out pulls his calf
right as he's going for the game time
field goal
yeah you gotta hate an offensive uh pass
interference just because they never
call it
so when they do call it it just seems
like it's this personal vendetta against
you and your team
um but you know there was a bad period
there where you could
you couldn't even look at a receiver and
they would throw a flag but i think
they've done a pretty good job
of uh correcting stuff like that but joe
burrow looked great totally looks like a
gamer
and that uh he's going to be able to
play at the nfl level which is awesome
i'm a huge lsu fan
nah they're such a fun team go tigers
edo
what a character they're they're a super
fun team
yeah so uh yeah i'm looking forward to
it i mean
i i i'm kind of happy now that there's
nfl football three days a week you know
i used to kind of complain about the
thursday afternoon
thursday game with the freaking the
awful uniforms and
and then how the color rush networking
for a while i couldn't get the nfl
network unless i changed my whole
whatever cable i had back then i was
kind of against it now during this crap
i'm actually loving it
yeah it gives you something to watch a
prime time game but uh yeah bengals
are getting six points in cleveland do
you think they cover do you think they
hang with the browns
yeah i think they beat him oh wow
outright i like it
come on there outright beat him it's one
of those stupid divisional rivalry games
i always hate betting those games too
but yeah i think the bengals going and
just straight up beat him
i know but cleveland has a good running
game right they have a good running back
yeah i know they got
they got nick chubb and kareem hunt i
think they could give
the bengals rush defense some problems i
think that's going to be
baker's still the quarterback though and
that that's probably the problem with
them
they didn't look too good week one i
just never seen a guy get so much [ __ ]
before he even played
yeah no he really baker's uh gotten a
ton of crap he's both gotten a lot of
[ __ ]
and been crowned all before he's done
anything and now
it is funny to watch him in those
commercials where the the stadium is his
house
and he's i mean 38 to six what was the
score it's not a good look
maybe maybe more football less acting it
it is brutal though when you're
when your quarterbacks getting destroyed
in the game and then they're having like
you know he's hanging out having fun
living at the stadium like i don't want
to see that right now like they need to
have a guy in there who if it's a
blowout pull all the baker commercials
work on your lines or work on the plays
not your lines just just for his own
sake i mean i get it you know you can be
in the nfl
and you know spend four hours at the
stadium cleveland's
entire problem is baker mayfield they
were kind of having a lot of problems
before he got there
and i think one of the worst things that
can happen to you if you're a high draft
pick as a quarterback is to go to the
cleveland browns
over the last almost 30 years so cut the
guy a little bit of slack
there's something about a white guy who
wears a bandana
white dude i don't know what it is what
does he think he's in a gang you just
started
all the way back to andre agassi people
just start trashing
yeah it's not it's you know people yeah
you think he's like an extra and sons of
anarchy
with the hair going in the bandana it's
that cobra kai look you know
another another kind of classic matchup
the monday night game the las vegas
raiders at home catching five and a half
against the saints where are you at with
uh john gruden uh bill are you are you a
big gruden guy
did you find it i love john gruden i
also that new stadium they have
oh man yeah they finally god knows you
know you wait
50 years to get a place to play 60 years
they've never really had um well i guess
the oakland a stadium at some point was
new but that was
those were those cookie cutter baseball
football ones so i'm excited to see
them in a uh a nice venue
unfortunately i think the saints are
going to give them their first loss
in that building um i don't know five
points doesn't scare me
yeah yeah drew brees in the dome
against john gruden there was that the
raiders just won a game
they're riding high this is the perfect
time to bet against and it is i mean we
drove by it in person recently and
it's it's just awesome to see it sitting
there right out in the strip it's hockey
puck almost yeah
it's very stadium the death star they're
calling it very futuristic it is going
to be crazy when they do let
fans go in there because i can just
imagine just marauding bands of raiders
fans getting drunk
all day on the strip and then just
rolling into that stadium
uh it's gonna be wild once they start
letting fans into that thing those
raider fans might get discovered on the
script the way they dress up
yeah you look great as uh in cirque du
soleil
well you know we saw the michaels
opening up next door so they can get
their craps and work on their uh
their plastic shoulder pads yeah they're
they're eye shadows
fights sticking out i don't know what
happened
i like to back in the 70s the raiders
fans look like a giant
biker gang yeah somewhere along the line
i don't know what they kind of uh they
got to get out of the
uh it's a little too much kiss it just
looks like they were hanging out on etsy
for an afternoon and got like oh
spiked styrofoam shoulder pads that'll
complete my outfits like come on
what happened to just get some fake
chains
yeah or they they have like the guy with
like the fighter pilot mask on with the
giant
like you know murdered out advisor it's
like come on dude
uh but the black hole is fun it'll be
great to see those guys in there
of course [ __ ] all over it i mean
it's fun in the you know because it's
it's just emblematic of the raiders and
kind of a fun tradition but yeah
getting dressed up in costumes and going
to football it's it's fun i mean come on
they can take a joke see the seahawks
they're at home they had a nice win week
one
patriots coming into seattle sunday
night i don't like this
seahawks laying four points ah man this
is a
it's a tough spot for the patriots early
but i said that last week and then they
took care of the dolphins
where where is your head at with this
game bill i don't think i know enough
about seattle but
um i do think that russell wilson
will you know basically cancels out cam
newton well that's that's a wash
and um i don't know like that's uh this
i think this is a big test early for us
playing with an above average team
because i do know that seattle has lost
did lose a lot of players i mean with
the free agency i can't keep up with it
so
it's hard for me to gamble in in in
september here but
uh my gut tells i would stay away from
this game because if i had to put money
on it i would i would
bet seattle seattle and laying the
points
they appear to be letting russ cook down
there i like bill with the emotional
hedge
betting against his team just because
then you can you kind of have yourself
covered i mean worst case scenario
seattle wins by three and then you don't
get the you don't hit the spread and
your team loses
every single time i've said i'm going to
bet against my team i failed to do so
are you do you do you find yourself i i
don't see you as this guy but
being superstitious having any sort of
rituals when your team is on
do you do you kind of get your kids i
know you have a couple young kids do you
try and get them
into into watching the game where are
you at with uh your team on game day
oh no i i you know i i don't i gave up
on superstitions uh
you know what finally made me give up on
superstitions i see here the longest
time uh
don't put it don't put a hat on a bed
head on a bed is bad luck
and i actually i don't know somebody
told me i sort of looked it up like
where that came from
like back in the day when you people
used to knit their own hats when they
take the hat off at night the static
electricity they would see the flashes
so they thought the devil lived in your
hair
so then if you so it was like in your
hat or something like that so you put
the hat on the bed the devil was in your
bed and then it was going to get into
you
and i was like that has got to be the
dumbest [ __ ] i've ever heard in my life
and after that i now move about freely
in my living room
i know that i have no effect on the game
whatsoever it's been liberating for like
the last 20
years so well i don't have any uh
superstition i will tell you though
is i don't have the stomach
to watch play off hoop when my team is
in it
because that whole thing where it's a
game of runs
it's just infuriating to me where my
team can't miss the other team can't hit
and all of a sudden
we forget how to play and then they
can't miss that doesn't happen in other
sports it's not like
if your offensive line is dominating the
defensive line
i don't care what kind of half-time
adjustments they make
you don't come out in the next half and
all of a sudden your team forgets how to
block
well i mean maybe the atlanta falcons in
the super bowl
where they were they were up 28-3 they
seem to forget something
but i know what you mean and it happens
like i swear to god it happens like
three times during an nba game yeah no i
mean nba will be up by like 25 and then
it'll just be 27
two run it's all tied up you're like
what the [ __ ] happened
well especially now when they when they
just like every guy is shooting threes
even like a seven foot guy from latvia
is still like chucking it up behind the
ark
and yeah it's so easy that they go hot
and cold the bubble the shooting
and the runs have been crazy because
there's no home court advantage so you
got teams like the nuggets and teams
like the miami heat who maybe
never would have made it if they were
actually traveling and playing in
hostile environments
but yeah it really feels like the last
six minutes of an nba
just wait till the game has eight
minutes left in it and then you can
watch it because if you watch it before
that you're just going to go on this
strange roller coaster ride that means
nothing
and that's essentially why i stopped
betting on the nba regularly because
it's just
it's not good for your heart it's like
jesus oh yeah and then also like the
last
five minutes takes like a half an hour
well and then they've
they've even added instant replay where
they're like going frame by frame to see
if it hit the guy's fingernail
it's like oh my god they got to do
something to like speed up the end of
the game
because that's that's what's fun about
basketball the intensity
the you know running up and down the
court the flow of the game
we sound like some grumpy old men sean
get off our level
it is true though but i will tell you
but then you got to sit there with your
stomach and knots for a half an hour
for something that should have taken
like maybe 10 minutes
no i know it it never goes away that
kind of knot you have when you're
when your team's playing it's a good
sweat you know sometimes one uh one
final game
worth hitting on that i care about
sports well i find myself
curse it's a curse i mean my wife will
like have to talk me down
after the eagle's law she goes you can't
do this to yourself you can't
you know be mad at yourself for
something that you have no control over
and the logical part of my brain is
going i know what you're saying i can't
control it
the other the the reptile part of the
brain is going you [ __ ] up you dumb
[ __ ] you wore the wrong hat
you knew what you're doing you let the
team down i'd like honestly
i i after a bad loss i go what could i
have done and i really
and i'm not i'm not an idiot i know i
can't do anything
but it's it must be you know irish
catholic
i don't know irish journal i wish i
could go back to the days before the
internet when you lost just your lies
yeah i have a direct connection to the
fans
of the team that just beat you like did
you see uh
you see magic johnson oh man he's great
he's hilarious
he went on and he trashed the clippers
when they listen la's always gonna be
like the lakers city
and just as a celtics man i was like
wait they were kind of sweating the
clippers when they were up three to one
they were like oh [ __ ]
and then all these people came out uh
i don't know i thought that was a bad
look yeah the lakers where it's like
dude you're the lakers you don't care
about these guys
no you actually have to make that la
will always be the lakers city it's just
like
you're sitting on 16 championships they
had zero
why would you take your time to answer
them no i don't
yeah it is you don't really need to
stoop down to the clipper's level if
you're a laker
you don't need to rub it into your
little brother yeah especially if you
love
i do love the clippers and i was rooting
for them but uh now i'm rooting for the
nuggets
oh yeah nuggets are nuggets are such a
fun team they do have kind of that like
rec league team vibe that just got hot
and you can't get them off the court
but uh joe kitch jamal murray is
shooting lights out there there's a lot
he's always seen to be able to buy the
two best guys in the league and then
that's it's
it's drives me nuts yeah yeah i mean
it seems as though the nba would love to
see a lakers celtics
bubble final so conspiracy theorists out
there
we could somehow uh appeal
to people to come to me and just be like
boston's like la it's just as racist as
l.a
the weather isn't as nice yeah we could
the boston can hang don't worry guys
all right bill one final game to hit on
a nice uh
nice quarterback battle here you got
lamar jackson and the ravens
coming just coming off a ass whoop under
the browns
going into uh houston to face the texans
texans are a seven point
home dog of course they uh they got
their ass kicked
opening night against the chief so they
have a little bit of long rest
what's your uh what's your lien here on
this game texans getting seven
they always pick the perfect number
don't the ravens are just you know
they're gonna beat them
it's like deshawn watson jj watts they
got those two pieces and i just don't
feel like
enough of the rest of the team works the
play calling i don't know what it is it
just doesn't seem to come together for
them
the ravens are perennial just a
successful
franchise and then they have this next
level guy at quarterback
oh man but given seven on the road
i know my brain wants to say hey you're
a smart gambler take the home dog
but then i look at that ravens team and
i didn't even think they would be
as good as they started out week one and
they just they're just an
unstoppable force doesn't i'm going
ravens i'm taking favorites this week
[ __ ]
some sometimes early in the season you
just gotta pick winners don't worry
about the spread pick winners
well yeah the ravens are winning this
game i'm with you houston maybe they get
in the back door but
bill o'brien once again looks like he's
unaware of how to drive
a national football league franchise and
and yet he still has the keys i don't
get it yeah no bill bryant was an
interesting guy where like i was
you know the trade he made getting rid
of deandre hopkins
and i mean you just got to feel like an
[ __ ] when he goes off and has a
career
game the first game after the trade so i
tried to defend him saying like oh i
think he's a pretty solid coach they
always win the division
so he must be doing something right but
then that game against kansas city like
he was just way too conservative you're
playing the chiefs
you can't be punting at midfield on like
fourth and three so
i don't know could be a long season for
bill o'brien and the texans
you don't think midfield against patrick
mahomes fourth and three you'd go for it
no no no i'm saying he should have yeah
yeah yeah
oh your house would be up for sale
pretty quick
oh that's an nfl coach this is i'm
telling you
you guys grew up playing madden football
i mean your idea
yeah i just you know fourth and three no
biggie
well we are we are a gambling podcast
and our our catchphrase is let it ride
so you're right maybe i wouldn't
i'd either flame out or become like a
coaching genius just
going for a crazy fourth down never
punting uh
you know as a fan you just want to see
crazy [ __ ] like that yeah you could be
down 42-0
going into the second quarter against
the chiefs doing that but i would love
to see a guy do that have the balls to
do it
oh yeah i mean and and and not to give
that guy in high school one year that
never
he never punted or kicked an extra point
he went forward on fourth down every
time and he went for
two every time well and that's what i
get coaches paying attention to that too
i also don't think he had the best
kickers he could have been a pro
the undefeated patriots we lost to the
giants in the super bowl
do you remember that fourth down
belichick went he went it was like a
fourth
and six yeah on the first drive we just
like went for it
and didn't get it and um i remember that
was like one of the few times i ever
questioned belichick i was like what the
hell was that
yeah no i mean it's game [ __ ] yeah
and and just immediately even if the
math supports it
you know it's like in in blackjack when
you got 16 and you're against a face
card
you know the number says like the card
that you get at the gift shop says
you're statistically better off hitting
and then when you do it in your bus
you're like oh what the [ __ ] but really
it's like
55 45. so you should do it the math says
do
but uh yeah i mean then you gotta live
with the results shoot or shoot sean
shoot or shoot shoot or shoot
all right bill so to run it down looks
like you're taking the bucks minus nine
the bangles plus six but you think they
got it they're given nine
yeah it's a big number for carolina
whoa and that's in carolina no that's in
tampa
all right you know they got the pirate
ship there'll be at least one and a half
pirates on it yeah
the hell with it there there could be
some actual pirates i mean who knows
what's going on in
tampa right now tampa minus nine bengals
plus six but you also think they have a
shot to win it outright
uh ravens minus seven in houston
new orleans minus five and a half in las
vegas
and then faden the new england patriots
not believing
in them uh seattle minus four for the
sunday night game
out of all of those i think the scentsy
pick is is the most solid
watch me eat my words all right lock
that up
bangles all right bill appreciate you
calling in and uh have a good uh nfl
weekend
all right guys thank you thanks for
checking out the sports gaming podcast
make sure you subscribe to our podcast
to hear us pick
every nfl game against the spread and
give us a follow on twitter at
gamblingpodcast
and of course if you want to play win
and get paid go to mybookie.ag
promo code burr
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday december 17
2012. um i am emotionally exhausted
from watching that patriots san
francisco game uh last night how insane
was that game
unbelievable um unfortunately it was
exactly what i thought
although the comeback i was amazed by
that but i i've i've
i've gotten so much [ __ ] from a couple
friends of mine who are patriots fans
because they feel like i'm not a
patriots fan anymore because i keep
talking about
how bad our defense is and uh they're
one of those people who like you know
they like dress like drew bledsoe when
they watch the game you know those
people
whether they're such [ __ ] fans that
no matter what's going on you you can
never
say anything what they deem is like
negative rather than constructive
criticism but you know
i feel vindicated because last week when
we beat the texans they were sitting
there going you see
look at that you know there's your
defense
what do you got to say now you read edit
cut yeah i didn't think so
get dicks out right
i've been telling the whole [ __ ] time
that the afc is weak
all right it's [ __ ] weak the nfc
has been far superior to the afc for
[ __ ] years
all right but the thing is you got brady
and belichick
and a little bit of luck and that's how
we got to the [ __ ] super bowl last
year we still almost won
but that doesn't change the fact that
our defense
sucks all right
oh we do good against the mediocre teams
and the so-called good teams in the afc
but i'm telling you right now we'll be
lucky if we get by the broncos
okay you let up [ __ ] 40-something
points to a second-year quarterback i
can't help you
why is my voice cracking because i've
been screaming at the [ __ ] tv for
three hours watching the damn thing
um yeah if the 49ers actually had a
quarterback they would have scored like
you know a more experienced quarterback
i'm not [ __ ] on their uh
their guy there with the soul patch
whatever the [ __ ] his name is at a boise
state who could have played baseball he
uh but he had one [ __ ] shot he took
how many [ __ ] times you tell that
story um
i mean he missed like two guys who will
have like three steps on our safety
i don't know [ __ ] brutal but i knew
it was gonna happen
i knew it was gonna happen you know what
i mean i mean i hate to say it but if
you know if the 49ers had aaron
rodgers uh drew brees a [ __ ]
you know eli manning you know it's we
can't compete with that
kills me kills me
i don't know what the [ __ ] we have to do
but uh you know we're all right we're
all right in the box
as they say but i swear to god our
[ __ ] past defense stinks
i don't i don't keep you know it just
it was you know it was enjoyable
watching the 49ers celebrating and
stomping around
doing that because they're doing their
job
all that dumb [ __ ] that every [ __ ]
athlete does now
you know you [ __ ] get a layup for two
points and then you go
[Music]
scare children in the front row like
like you this like you're actually in
you know why don't you just [ __ ] bend
over and blow yourself at that point
i really enjoyed watching the 49ers do
that and then get that deer in their
headlights look as brady
calmly just just dismantled their
[ __ ] awesome defense
and tied it up and scored like 34 points
in like basically a quarter
i did enjoy 31 whatever the [ __ ] it was
i did enjoy that watching them have to
stand down and actually having
seeing that glazed over look oh and now
the phone rings
now the [ __ ] phone rings could
anything else be going on with this
podcast
just seeing that glazed over look on jim
harbaugh's face
was enjoyable but i [ __ ] loved that
guy and i loved the uh
the fake punt call in the first first
quarter
on your own 40 was that was that was
awesome
i i had to respect it it's like this guy
is going for the jugular
i mean those guys honestly could have
been up like 21-0 after like six minutes
in the game
um yeah so there you go
there's a great nice big bucket of ice
water
to the face of uh delusional patriots
fans that's that's what it is
that's where our defense is against um
the elite teams
you know sucks i'm not happy about it
and um
yeah i'm not [ __ ] happy about it i
just wish we
could we could oh for [ __ ] sakes with
you [ __ ]
you know what i hate about this [ __ ]
stupid phone besides everything
so you have the [ __ ] thing on mute it
still makes noise
like like i get important phone calls
right clio what am i the president
does it really need to do that even when
you [ __ ] put it on on silent mode
it still vibrates i guess i could just
shut
the thing off right
i never i never even thought to do that
that's great i worked that out oh yeah
of course my password doesn't work on
the [ __ ] computer
this is just gonna be one of these days
you know i know it's gonna be one of
these days as i took my dog out for a
walk
and um she took a [ __ ] and unlike
rapaport i went to pick the [ __ ]
thing up
right and i had my headphones on and as
i bent over to do it my headphones fell
down and almost landed in the pile of
dog [ __ ]
and uh rather than laughing it off
like somebody with rosy cheeks would um
i'm a cynical bastard so i took that as
an omen
on how this day was gonna be and uh it's
lived up that way
i had a bowl of cereal this morning i
almost [ __ ] died
and you know what's funny is the lovely
nia was
literally maybe seven feet away in the
other room
and never checked on me
could give a [ __ ] you know you know what
that is
it's like we've been together when
you've been with somebody as long as i
have
they just it's not like they want you to
die
it's a combination of two things they
they
they just tune you out so i could have
been in there
talking to her about how you know my
headphones almost fell into the dog [ __ ]
this morning
or i could have been almost choking to
death either way she doesn't even hear
it and then like subconsciously
it's not that they want you to die but
they
not fatally but if you could die for
like three hours
you know i don't think that they would
be upset just sort of
you know drag you over and put you
behind the couch
and just you know fantasize about being
single again for like three hours and
then you you know you wake up
like in one of those those movies with
kefir sutherland what was that movie
called
shockers it wasn't clockers that was
spike lee i don't know
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was
anyways this is what happened
i was eating uh i corn chex
i'm a big fan of the chex family all
right this isn't some sort of subtle
advertising i'm trying to put in here
okay this is this is coming from my
heart not my wallet
all right i like to check cereals i'm
not into rice chex that has nothing to
do
with world war ii or vietnam okay i just
don't like the taste of them
okay i'm not coming at you with some red
state [ __ ] i ain't eating nothing that
got [ __ ] rice in it after what
happened over there
and uh uh the dmz i'm not coming at you
like that
i just don't like the taste of that one
i either go corn chex or i go weak
checks
so here's the yeah you know what i
noticed the other day is this this
morning when as i was almost choking to
death on my cereal was
all cereal is kind of the same color you
notice that
it's all sort of [ __ ] just different
kind of browns
isn't that weird isn't that weird that
that would go through my head as i'm
almost
dying choking that [ __ ]
bad 80s comedian analogy went through my
head
that would that might have been my last
thought
you know or like it's like a topic you'd
hear on like npr
all things considered today we discuss
the different shades of brown and
breakfast cereals
i don't care if you're eating rice chex
corn chex
wheat chex rice krispies or corn flakes
the all too familiar off color band-aid
brown on all things considered um yeah
we listen to npr nia listens to that
[ __ ] she's such a [ __ ] nerd and she
always has it on and i'm
i and you know i don't know there's
really no good radio stations out here
as far as like playing music
out here in la i don't know why
i don't know what i don't know what goes
on out here but evidently
uh these the two bands that they play
they play them like it's still 19 the
early 90s
they play ice cube all the time
badam when you come to my town badam
like
like i don't know why they play it like
they play it enough
like you think he he died or something
you know and then uh and then they also
play the
uh who are those guys
whatever the [ __ ] they are pretty fly
for a white guy they play them all the
[ __ ] time
you know like everybody's still walking
around in flannels going hey have you
heard the new pearl jam
man um anyways
so here's the story i basically go to
get my [ __ ] box of corn checks
i pick up the box immediately i notice
it's pretty light you know pour it in
get a full bowl and there's like an
eighth of a box left now i could be a
douche and put the box back
and give me a false hope oh i want a box
you know i want a bowl of cereal you
know and then she grabs the box and she
fills the lightness
then that panic comes in you start to
sweat like oh [ __ ]
you start pouring it out come on man
keep going and there's only an eighth of
a bowl left
you know the douche puts that back in
the cupboard
the gentleman the refined individual
like myself
you just say all right i'm gonna have a
little more cereal than i usually have
so that's what i did all right i started
eating the [ __ ] cereal and i'm
wolfing it down because i know the
podcast is a little bit late
and i'm gonna get a bunch of [ __ ] on
twitter right
so i get about halfway done with my bowl
i take the box of cereal and i pour that
last eighth in you know the deal
the last part of the box that's the most
dangerous part of the box
you know you got half it's half of its
cereal and the rest of it's all [ __ ]
powdered so all the powder goes on my
on the top of the cereal i start eating
the [ __ ] and i'm doing that you know
eating so fast
you're eating and inhaling through your
[ __ ] pie hole you're
doing that [ __ ] and i had a half a spoon
of powder the other half was the cereal
and i inhaled the [ __ ] and
my my throat just closed off
and i thought i was gonna i thought at
the very least i was gonna pass out to
the point i was i was debating
as i'm coughing and hacking away and nia
is completely ignoring me
um i'm sitting this
pounding i'm thinking should i make them
loud noise in the kitchen
or should i run to you know five steps
to the bedroom but then i'm thinking
well that like take up too much oxygen
and um i basically was choking on this
[ __ ] for three straight minutes and nia
didn't
move a [ __ ] muscle didn't move a
goddamn muscle
and when i finally i finally uh realized
i was going to live
i was so pissed at her that you know
like after you get done choking like you
your voice is like
it's like turned down to one so you're
trying to talk it's like
you know thanks for helping you know
that type of [ __ ]
i basically said sarcastically thanks
for helping in the i was just choking
for
three minutes voice and all i get for
neo is like oh i'm sorry
are you okay
you know is that any way to start the
[ __ ] day
i don't think is that was that even
funny was that even remotely amusing to
you i i don't know
i almost died this morning i don't care
if i'm funny or not
cleo um
all right let's do let's do a little
advertising here and then i'm going to
talk to you about this 30 for 30 i
watched called broke
all right um where are we oh we got a
new we got new advertising this week
everybody cascade studios
cascade studios on santa monica
boulevard
out here in los angeles we got a local
ad here
um this is a rehearsal studio um
if you're in a band basically and you
need a rehearsal space cascade studios
is the number one place here in
los angeles this is when i go down i
play drums and i try to
pull off that bottom stuff trying to get
my foot as fast as his this is where i
go i go to cascade studios 6611 santa
monica boulevard
if you want to go down there with your
whole band they got a five piece drum
kit in every room with high hats
two guitar ramps bass amp pa system with
three mics
symbol rental is only five bucks um
or if you're just a drummer like myself
and you want to go down there with your
ipod
and beat the hell out of a kit and have
a great time he charges you 15 bucks for
an
hour i highly recommend it um i go down
there all the time
if you go down ask for joe tell him the
monday morning podcast sent you
and as always everybody it's stamps.com
um with the holidays all almost here you
don't have time to go to the post office
there's traffic there's parking there's
somebody in front of you is going to
have like 90 boxes that they're sending
out to all their grandkids
you know as they take out the changed
person their hand is shaking
right it's going to be packed with
everyone mailing out holiday gifts is
what i'm trying to say and packages
so what do i do i use stamps.com instead
stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle
of going to the post office during the
busy holiday season
everything you would do at the post
office you can do right from your desk
or your apartment wherever the hell
you're at um buy and print official us
postage using your own computer and
printer
print postage for any letter or package
the instant you need it
then the mailman comes and picks it up
it's so easy and convenient you don't
have to go down to the post office and
deal with everything that i just
described
i use stamps.com to send out all the
merch from my shows
you should do it too well i guess you
shouldn't unless you're doing a show
but whatever if you got all these
christmas gifts
that's the way to send it out stamps.com
right now get this special offer when
you use my last name bur
b-u-r-r for a no-risk trial plus 110
dollar bonus offer
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage they're giving you
during the holiday season don't wait go
to stamps.com right now before you do
anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in burr b-u-r-r
that stance dot com enter burr b-u-r-r
alrighty back to the podcast so i was
watching um
i was watching one of those 30 for 30s
um and they did this whole thing on on
athletes going broke
it was really bad there's a ton of
people who've gone broke most of them
didn't want to do the documentary
like why would you you know what i mean
hey you want to talk about how you
completely [ __ ] blew it no i don't
i don't and i resent the fact at the end
of your documentary you're going to be
running a list with my name on it
you know that's what they had at the end
of it but um
i was watching it and i felt bad for
people but after a while it was just the
same
[ __ ] story over and over again
and it's as much as i want to say that
if i was 21 years old and you gave me a
million dollars
that i would probably [ __ ] it up too i
i just don't think i would you know
i had these guys you know i i got a
check for 55 000
and i saw a hummer i had to get it talk
the guy down to forty nine thousand
dollars
and it's like if you just gotta check
for 55 [ __ ] grand
after paying all the people in your life
your agent whoever else you got where
else is taking it your lawyer whoever
else takes a chunk out of that check
whatever's left out of that the
government's going to come in and take a
40 percent whack if you get a check for
55 grand i mean what do you got left
20 grand you just went out and bought a
50 000 hummer
i don't know but anyways the point i
wanted to make was at the end of it
after showing all these people going
through this hell they have this guy
there who's supposed to be
evidently some sort of uh financial
advisor
and in the end they were talking about
lebron james going he is going to be
he has the potential to be other than
tiger woods
pre-divorce um
a billionaire athlete and they like how
exciting is that
and they go what what would your advice
be to this to lebron james
on how to hang on to his billion dollars
and the guy goes
he goes don't blow it keep it simple
count your money
that's what he said
it might have been the dumbest thing i
ever heard and i immediately
i had no sympathy for anybody
in the [ __ ] documentary it's just
like
even like why is this guy on this
document who the [ __ ] is that guy
that's a guy who manages money that's
hey i got a billion dollars
how do i hold on to this where should i
invest it
what do i do what advice do you got for
me
well it's simple don't blow it keep it
simple
count your money all right thanks a lot
i'll be i'm out of here
[ __ ] ridiculous it was basically it
was an hour and a half of listening to
morons telling you what the [ __ ] they
bought with all their money and i
i don't know i felt bad
but there was another part there was
just one guy that i really felt bad for
because it was
the hurt that he had you know
like andre uh ryzen was on the thing and
he's sitting there in his suit with
sunglasses on
mirrored sunglasses doing the interview
and just right there it's like yeah dude
i'd give you another million if i had it
if i gave it to you
you'd [ __ ] that up why because
you're sitting here in a shiny suit with
[ __ ] sunglasses on
looking like michael jackson at the
award show right
so anyways the one guy who actually
really bothered me was this
if you ever watch it it's 30 for 30
broke
there's a guy who's sitting there and
he's just
ever so slightly leaned to one side
and just the the pain
in in his voice he's just
just sitting there going uh i made uh
75 million dollars in my career and uh
had me a mercedes got a hummer
got me a boat he's just sitting there
looking down on his knee like playing
with his pant leg
i had a jet ski and
and you just i had to look away it was
[ __ ]
brutal but the rest of it was just a
bunch of knuckleheads
you know i felt bad for bernie kozar too
because bernie kozar
you know i don't know it seemed like his
dad took his money i don't know what the
[ __ ] it was it was
it's it's a really it's a it's a great
all the 30 for 30s are awesome this one
is awesome
but they just should have had a couple
of
they did you know something that's not
true because they had like four or five
guys
there was only two people who really
came off like morons
but they were just so they were such
morons that i felt it tainted the whole
thing
ugh that might have been the dumbest
thing i ever heard
what is your advice don't blow it keep
it simple
count your money
all right i'm sorry was it was that even
remotely [ __ ] interesting
i love watching those 30 for 30s i got
to watch the bo jackson one
um there was just something about that
like you know for as
much as they showed the amount of people
that went broke there's been so many
more people in the league
that didn't go broke so really weren't
you just showing
a select group of morons
you know who were going out and buying a
corvette and sticking a [ __ ] hot tub
in the back of it
you know living week to week on
paychecks i mean i just don't think that
most people are doing that
i would really think that if if i was
barely on the team
i would be saving every dime i know i
would
i've done that in this business i've
never [ __ ]
you know it's coming if you're in any
sort of entertainment
you know it's coming and the day it's
coming
is the day you think that you're good
and that you made it that's when
somebody comes in with the hood on and
the sickle
and they just [ __ ] chop you in half
and then that's it and then you're that
guy on tv
[ __ ] lean into maybe that's why that
guy was leaned to one side they had to
twist his torso back onto some fake legs
as he sat there going like i got me a
cabin
bought a mountain ah
you know you'd think that if you had 75
million dollars that you couldn't have
you know that [ __ ] goes
and and when it when it goes uh
there's nobody around
um anyways i gotta watch it a few more
times i feel like there's com there's
some sort of comedy in there
i just don't know if i got to it today
uh
anyways i've been drinking like a
[ __ ] madman lately i really have to
stop
i just keep going to these these friggin
uh christmas parties
you know and they got booze there
so yeah you know something maybe that if
i got like a zillion dollars maybe that
that's what i would have would have done
would have gone out and become a
complete freaking booze bag
now what the [ __ ] did i do with my notes
here
oh for christ's sake i swear to god this
is just it's not my day
it's not here it's not there it's not
here it's not there what the [ __ ] is it
there it is you know what let's read a
question here my brain is
suffering from lack of oxygen here let's
just read a question
college duet hey man i'll keep this
question
short i got my eye on this broad she
heard me playing music in the dorms
knocked
on my door i invited her in and we
talked for a bit jesus christ dude
i don't think you need any advice that
sounds like you're already there
she just heard your talent and came
knocking on your door what more does she
have to do
you know pull up her dress and back her
way in
anyways oh she said she wants to do
duets together
my fault i didn't realize she was also
in the business oh
jesus oh jesus um
anyway second time i wasn't playing
music but she knocked on the door and
started talking about duets again
not sure if she wanted to play then or
what but i was busy studying so i
invited her
in again and we talked yet again
dude you're only going to get so many at
bats where it's going to be weird
if you finally [ __ ] make a move all
right
what are you doing i i this is where did
that come from
um anyways i figure i'll invite her down
i have a single dorm with her instrument
once the workload didn't really sound
good
what i figure i'll invite her down i
have a single dorm with her instrument
once the workload
after holidays dies down and just kiss
her
and see what happens oh this is just a
band geek
all right what are you doing hey come on
over and and bring your
your bassoon and then she's going to
walk in you're just going to kiss her
please tell me there's going to be some
sort of preamble of making her laugh or
or something you at least going to try
to light a candle
anyways he says how does that sound any
advice i've had almost no interaction
with her before
or after this by the way uh okay
he goes love the podcast keep it up
you're a great guy just kidding
[ __ ] you
all right um
what what do you want to do with her you
just want a banger if you just want a
banger what you have to do is just
you have to stop acting like a gentleman
and i don't mean that in some sort of
gropey
disgusting manner what i mean is you
have to
you have to not just say
this [ __ ] you're thinking all right
just say the [ __ ] you're thinking and
say what you want to do
all right if it's one of those but if
this girl but if the girl is like uh
i don't know she's more walled off i
don't know what the [ __ ] word is
i think that brain cell died when i
inhaled the power powder this morning
um she's more walled off that i don't
know she's like a nerd i don't know what
to tell you
i never was able to interact
with female nerds beyond just talking to
them because
they were just so [ __ ] i don't like
everything was like awkward
so and then after that i was just like
you know what i could literally
rub one out faster than it's gonna take
for me to figure out just how to get her
glasses off
so yeah dude just invite her down
[ __ ] her instrument you know get the
music out of it
and just say hey i'm you want to come
down i'm watching a movie tonight just
get her over there
all right i don't know i don't know
where you've gone with the conversation
so far
if it's gonna seem weird if all of a
sudden you're sitting there
and you're hugh hefner rope but that's
the vibe i would have tried to bring if
you just want to bang her
that's what i would do if you want if
you want to date this girl
then i'd take her out but if you just
want a banger you you
you have to start acting like a [ __ ]
um
crass individual sooner rather than
later
you know you know it's a good way to
kind of
bring it into the sex thing is if you're
watching tv and just start talking about
some [ __ ] girl on the tv how hot you
think she is and blah blah blah
hopefully that'll spin her around and be
like why what do you find attractive
in a woman and then you just [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah well like take a
look at you you kind of got your [ __ ]
titties there
sitting in my phone right and then
you're in
right does that work i hope it works for
you sir
because i think you are a great guy
you're a great guy because you
you're sitting in the dorm and you're
you're practicing your [ __ ] piccolo
um all right next one
actually you know what that reminds me
of a long time ago
a long time ago i went to this girl's
dorm
and she wanted me to and i wanted to and
i didn't know how to [ __ ] bridge that
gap and we sat on her [ __ ]
single bed for like till my ass fell
asleep and i finally ended
up just i just finally just said i have
to just get out of here i don't know how
to
you know what i mean i i don't i don't
know how to [ __ ] crack the safe
so i should have been a little more
empathetic god i was pathetic
i was i was [ __ ] pathetic
not saying i'm i mean i think that's
been a through line in my life just
being pathetic but
it's sort of morphed you know
every time i feel like oh you know hey
kind of got that settled then there's a
new thing
you know like say podcasting
i feel like this is a pretty pathetic
attempt this week don't you
well go [ __ ] yourself hit the stop
button i don't give a [ __ ]
i really don't that's one of the great
things about this this podcasting world
is you really don't have to give a [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is the man great thing
there it is hey everybody this holiday
season
this holiday season think the man great
what is the man great you ask
they're made of 100 they're 100 percent
made in america cast iron grilling
grates
that are revolutionizing the way people
grill
um named one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine now
come on
men's health magazine you know they're
trying to teach guys how to be
guys a guy grilling it doesn't get any
more manlier than that and it was named
one of 2012's best grilling accessories
i don't know what else you need to know
man greats are the perfect gift this
holiday season click on the man great
banner
on billboard.com on the podcast page for
their 1999
holiday special this is a 20 gift that
i'm telling you it's gonna change your
life
this is such a great gift to get your
dad okay if your dad's a man
and he grills he's not upstairs eating
bok choy
you know if your dad goes out and he
shoots a pheasant
ties it to the uh the rear view mirror
and drives home with it
letting the blood drip down on the radio
this is what you want you want the man
great system get it for him
again it's the man that's the man great
grill enhancement system
order today at billboard.com click on
the podcast page
and uh and get yourself one today for
only 19.99 the holiday special
all righty okay there you go
the [ __ ] that reminded me of something
in the middle there
the hell was i gonna talk about
oh i know you know what i was gonna make
uh i was gonna try to make this
shepherd's pie this week every once in a
while i get like really into cooking
it's usually when i have a downtime in
this business and this time of year i
always take uh
i always take some time off you know i
don't like working over the holidays
i did enough of those [ __ ] awful uh
new year's eve gigs
you know you're in some god forsaken
[ __ ] strip mall
in the middle of nowhere you're all by
yourself
you go on stage you got like a 50 50
chance that they already handed out the
[ __ ] noisemakers
you're standing up there eating your
balls and then they make you do the
countdown
stop your act did i talk about this last
week i feel like i already did i'll fast
forward to this [ __ ] and then you got to
somehow
then they want you to continue your act
after the countdown it's the worst
[ __ ] thing ever
and everybody's hugging and kissing and
that type of [ __ ] you're standing up
there by yourself like the absolute
you know cliched entertainer
you know sitting there crying in your
tuxedo
so anyway so i usually i take this time
a year off and i uh i start
i always get i get into cooking cleo
stop staring at me
come here stop staring at me
so anyways um i'm a big mario batali fan
right
so i made these braised short ribs
that were the [ __ ] [ __ ] i went out
and got myself a dutch oven
you know which because of that joke has
really been ruined there's no way to
[ __ ] say dutch oven
and cooking without somebody thinking
about somebody farting under the
blankets and pulling it over your face
but i made these braised short ribs that
have been the [ __ ] but nia's on a
[ __ ] diet so she's not eating any of
them so i ate like half a pig myself
and i don't think my belly has ever been
rounder or whiter
i have like one of those toddler
stomachs you know those little
beer bellies that they have you know
what i'm talking about cleo
cleo do you want to finish the rest of
this podcast
do you well then get off me
the [ __ ] dog is so goddamn needy um
all right let's continue on here with
the questions for this week
if i can find it my computer of course i
can't because this is just how my day's
been working i should have known
you know i should have gone right back
to bed the [ __ ]
the second my headphones almost fell in
dog [ __ ] isn't that isn't that like a
sign
that you should end the [ __ ] podcast
33 minutes and this is brutal
brutal all right doucheboss dear bill
first i want to say
uh um i have all the episodes of
uninform you did with the teen idol
sensation on my phone and listen to them
every day
but on to my dilemma i'm 18 and work at
the finish line
at the mall and my boss is a complete
dick
of course he is because he's managed
managing a finish line at the mall
you're 18. you got your whole life ahead
of you he probably [ __ ] married the
wrong person
he's starting to go bald he's standing
there wearing that referee uniform
going hey what did i tell you about the
chuck taylors you know i thought i told
you to [ __ ] stalk them up in the back
whatever the hell they say don't you
just want to choke him with his whistle
do they make you wear whistles there or
is that athlete's foot or is that the
foot locker
i don't know actually you know something
i have like the the worst collection
of dirty white boys sneakers you're ever
going to see in your life
every time i look at my sneaker
collection i picture
you know keith robinson or patrice
if he was still alive god damn it um
just trashing me you know what's funny
about how much i miss patrice is the
amount of times
is when i i i miss that guy
how the [ __ ] do i tell the story without
[ __ ] outing somebody
somebody told gave a [ __ ] speech you
know or whatever went on some rant about
the state of comedy and everybody
thought it was [ __ ] amazing it was
just one of those times where i wish
patrice was in the room when this person
was [ __ ]
pro you know was was talking about it
that's when i missed that dude the
[ __ ] most i missed him then i missed
him when
um penn state that sandusky guy
when he did when he gave the [ __ ]
interview
you know that interview when he i think
he was talking to bob costas and they
were going do you
uh do you like little boys and he was
like
do i like little boys i mean i
enjoy their company and you know
somebody says do you like little boys
there's one [ __ ] answer no
no i don't okay
and [ __ ] you for asking me that and this
guy's sitting there like you know
like trying to work out the math in his
head and as
i as creepy as it was to watch that when
i
watched it i was actually laughing
thinking of patrice watching it laughing
hysterically
and how he would somehow get 25 minutes
of material just out of that guy
trying to figure out how to answer that
that question and i swear to god like i
don't know
we got this benefit coming up for him
and as just putting the thing together
it's just like going through him dying
all over again it's been [ __ ] brutal
but good and a good positive things
because everybody bought up the tickets
but it's just been like this [ __ ]
uh the finality of it it's just
something like on that i even talked to
all my buddies like we bring him up like
he's still around
and we'll talk about him like he's still
around for five minutes before you just
start looking at the ground it's just
[ __ ] awful
i really i really do not wish that you
know i don't know why you would but and
it's not even
worth even stating but i really don't
wish this on [ __ ] anybody because uh
it's really just something when i'm 80
well
if i'm lucky enough you know the way
i've been drinking lately
let's just be a little more conservative
i'm 68.
[Laughter]
it's just something that's still just
going to be i've just i'm coming to an
acceptance that it's going to be as
sad when i'm that age as it is right now
you know so i figured i'd talk about
that to add to the already
not hilarious podcast that i'm doing
this week i'd add to the uh losing a
close friend
[ __ ] vibe you know
who's getting who it really wasn't a
funny [ __ ] week out in the world
uh all right doucheboss where are we
here um
at the finish line he is one of those
guys who okay his boss is a complete
dick all right he says uh
he's one of those guys who got bullied
all through high school and now actually
has some control
and takes it out on me and and the other
employees
how did you figure that out is that you
just like psychologically breaking the
guy down
do i have to tell you something there's
nothing worse
than watching somebody uh
abuse their position of power however
however small it is
you know like this guy right here has no
right getting mad at like an athlete who
goes around being a dick because it's
like dude you're doing the exact same
thing you just can't run a 440
but your your head space is the exact
same place
as some you know egomaniac [ __ ]
athlete you just you just suck at sports
so you sell the gear two people to go
play sports
anyways he says he even steals out of
the register at work
and holds the special release shoes for
him and his friends
he's 30 years old and tries to [ __ ] the
16s and 17 year olds who work there
oh my god this guy is a character right
out of the movies
you know i worked with a guy like this i
used to work in a restaurant a long time
ago
sorry i'm trying to get the czech cereal
out of my throat
um i used to work with this this guy and
basically like
four or five of these guys bought into a
restaurant
and and the one guy who's going to be
there every day
who's always the guy who ends up
stealing the silent partners always get
[ __ ]
his his buy-in was he had all the the
equipment for the kitchen
so he he he i don't know he had some
other failed restaurant he got all the
equipment
and uh but anyways this guy was a
cokehead he used to steal out of the
register
he used to [ __ ] uh try to bang the uh
not the maitre d the [ __ ] uh
matrodius whatever the [ __ ] chick who
sits you down the hot one
you know who dresses classy that skirt
[ __ ] going right over her shapely ass
yeah he used to try to [ __ ] bang them
all the goddamn time and when they
wouldn't give it up
they'd get fired and then he'd be
bringing a new one
if that one ended up banging him then
she stuck around was brutal
so anyways he goes uh he harasses me and
others calling our phones repeatedly
telling us to come in on our days off
and leaves voicemails saying
we are ignoring him jesus christ my
[ __ ] day off anyways he goes recently
he got the only cool management manager
fired
because he said he was stealing i don't
really need this job but would like to
keep working here but don't know how
much longer i can take this any advice
on what i should do
would be appreciated uh sorry for it
being so long go [ __ ] yourself uh it
wasn't long at all
it just sounded long the way i read um
well if you don't need the job then i
would i would quit
but what i wouldn't do is i wouldn't
leave
on bad terms i don't know is it really
going to matter
it's not like when you're 30 if you're
looking for a new job you're going to
put on your resume i worked at the
finish line
because at that point you're going to be
into a career
i don't you say i don't really need this
job but would like to keep working here
but don't know oh so
basically saying you like having walk
around money well i would just get
another job
just get another job start the process
of getting the [ __ ] out of there
like nothing you're going to say to that
guy is going to change that guy and all
that guy can do is kind of make your
life difficult
if you're trying to get another job at
this point in your life
just know that like he's at the tip of
the iceberg of the awful life that he's
going to be living
um like
just what the way he's setting the table
you don't need to do anything to him
because he's going to do it to himself
and it would really be bad if if this
guy was just such a negative force you
somehow got sucked into it i know you
probably fantasized
about punching him in the face or
telling the guy to go [ __ ] himself
and then the girl that you have the
crush on at the finish line walks out
arm and arm with you guys and you start
your own sneaker store right across
and you watch him get fired i know
you've probably played that fantasy out
in your head a hundred times but uh
i would just get another job sound like
you don't mind working you're not afraid
of working
you like having the money but you just
can't deal with this douche so this is a
great life lesson
you do not need to be surrounded by
douches you have the power it's your
[ __ ] life
just he's always going to be a douche
just walk out of his life just be like
yeah you know i don't need to be around
this guy
you know and then one day when you run
into him after you get another job
hey how come you uh left and just be
like you know cuz uh
i don't know dude you were just and
don't curse at him or anything because
then
it gives him an excuse
to not see himself and just be like i
don't know man you the
you just kind of creep me out the way
you were always hitting on girls who
were like 16 and 17 years old and if
that's what you want to do i mean you
know
that's cool but uh you know i'm just
kind of not into that
so uh you have yourself a nice evening
you just walk away from them
maybe it'll work out like that i have no
idea but uh
i try and get yourself another job all
right there you go that's my advice all
right
here's another next one uh multiple [ __ ]
buddies gone wrong
you know what dude just the fact that
you had multiple [ __ ] buddies
uh it's it's still a win
you know what i mean it's still a win
you made the playoffs
um hey billy boy first time long time
i got i'm gonna get right into it all
right last weekend i got a text from a
former [ __ ] buddy who found out that i
had slept with their friend
before we started hooking up oh you know
what go [ __ ] yourself
all right you're crushing ass all over
the place you don't need my advice i
probably need advice from you
that's all that's a secret goal of of a
certain percentage of guys
is like what if i can [ __ ] her and all
of her friends before they all figure it
out
you know what i mean it's sort of like
an action movie with your dick
and
can i stick it in all of them before the
bomb goes off
and uh and can i get out of town like
[ __ ] de niro and heat
before i see all of them coming up
with the how dare you have you ever
fantasized
about doing that and you were so good
that as mad as they were they all
reminisced about how great you were and
then all four of them come over and be
like ah we're all [ __ ] at the same time
if you haven't had that fantasy god
bless you because you're evidently a way
more decent a human being than i am
so anyways with that
here we go um he goes she sends me
anyway let me just refresh your memory
here last weekend i got a text from a
former [ __ ] buddy who found out that i
had slept with her friend
before we started hooking up she sends
me a pretty heated two-page text
about how much of a dog and douchebag i
am
for sleeping with her friend then
[ __ ] her the same weekend
yeah dude dude you're a legend you're a
[ __ ] legend what is the
dude all you can do is just stand there
with your hand at your sides
take the slap to the face and just know
that yeah you're a hero
dude you banged her friend and and her
in the same weekend and you're you're
you you don't front a rock a successful
band i mean that's that's
you know my hat's off to you sir
hats off to you anyways he goes now in
reality
i had slept with the friend in late may
and then starting hook
hooking up with the [ __ ] buddy in early
september oh okay so she tried to make
it more dramatic that's still great dude
you you seamlessly made the shift over
the summer
you're still a hero um anyways he goes
to go into a little more detail the [ __ ]
buddy had gone on several dates
and [ __ ] once three oh i had gone on
several dates with her and [ __ ] once
three years prior when we were both at
college
but then shortly after she lost interest
and we remained
as friends for the next few years when i
say friends i mean the occasional text
and seeing each other maybe three or
four times
all right so what is your [ __ ]
problem
what is the rule shouldn't shouldn't the
second one be mad at you because you
[ __ ] the other one first
i don't i'll never understand
i never understand what can any female
if you're still listening at this point
if i have any female listeners at this
point can you explain to me
why that makes you mad
you know because i don't know there was
always like
there was always that girl that like you
know when i was growing up like
i can't say me because i wasn't getting
anything i didn't get anything in high
school
big [ __ ] goose egg i would make my
my [ __ ] getting career in high school i
was like
the first year the tampa bay buccaneers
came in the league
and went winless
what was the name of there gary huff
was that the name of that quarterback i
was the gary huff of [ __ ] in
in in high school whatever the hell that
can't remember the name
his last name was huff who's the name of
their quarterback with cream sickle
[ __ ] uniform
i mean i had a suit made out of that
when i was in high school um
i but anyways there were there were
those girls that like
my drinking body crew like three or four
of them
out of the five had all hooked up with
her
and none of them were none of nobody was
mad everybody high five that's [ __ ]
great
that's you know we thought it was a
great thing i don't understand why they
get so mad
you know what it is is i i just think
that they want to uh
it's a big thing with them that it has
to be difficult
and you know and if they i think they
just feel like
if you bang them and their friend
they just somehow feel like maybe makes
them feel cheaper
that there's you're just [ __ ] hitting
it's like you're a machine gun you're
just mowing them down i think that they
really want to believe that they're the
only one in that area code
you know that they're like uh
that it's like gold rather than like
pine cones
[Music]
[Laughter]
you gotta dig for it it's precious metal
they don't they
they don't want to feel like they're
just like litter in the gutter
maybe that's what i have no i have no
idea but i have learned something in
this [ __ ] buddy is two words
this guy put [ __ ] buddy together um
that's how much he's into sex right now
he's
he's literally like the [ __ ] is is got
the body part bent over
and it's all one word they are one um
so anyways he said to go into a little
more detail i already read that part he
said so fast forward three years
and the friend of hers that's the future
[ __ ] buddy
said that we should hang out after the
sox game
all right i'm getting lost in this with
all my rambling
you know what the [ __ ] so you hooked up
with the former [ __ ] buddy
so now okay so this is when when when
number two comes in
before you went back to number one
all right so fast forward three years
later yes so she didn't give a [ __ ]
so who she should be mad at is the
second one no but it's been three years
you know i really don't think anybody
has a right to be mad here
all right whatever we should hang out
after a sox game of course i see this is
a green light because whenever a girl
that you really don't know says we
should hang out his codes for i'm down
to [ __ ]
exactly did you hear that uh guy with
the [ __ ]
bassoon you got they they speak in code
we should hang out sometime that that's
literally that's what that means
if they say would you everything you're
taking me out that means they want a
relationship we should hang out sometime
that's what that means okay and i'm not
saying 100 percent
i'm just saying it's it's looking good
you're getting waved around by the third
base coach
um anyways
where the hell am oh for [ __ ] sakes i
i apologize guys
when a girl says hey don [ __ ] so oh so
anyways so we end up [ __ ]
and she gets on a plane the next day to
study abroad in europe for the summer
exactly she wanted some shoving off dick
you know let me get a little last piece
of america before
i go over to europe tremendous anyways
fast forward three months later
and the [ __ ] buddy all one word says
that i should come over
some weekend to hang out green light we
bang it's great and we continue to do it
until the end of the month when i fly
back
to the place that i now live so a few
days ago i get the heated text saying
i'm a dog i'm a douchebag and she
thought i was a friend
etc i say that there's nothing i can do
or say to change what happened and the
only thing that i could say is i'm sorry
if i heard her
and that i am an [ __ ] but my question
to you
uh mr no relationship psychology degree
comedian
is am i a dog for what i did
no you're not
you're not and [ __ ] these women who call
you up and use you like a [ __ ] stick
all right they called you up because
they wanted some dick and you gave it to
him all right you gave him what the [ __ ]
they asked for
and then she's gonna turn around and get
mad at you
and then you apologize and say yeah i'm
an [ __ ] you're not an [ __ ] but you
know something
i don't think you think you're an
[ __ ] because you're out there
crushing it you're just [ __ ] saying
what you know this girl wants to hear
because probably six months from now
she's gonna [ __ ] you again
right you're not an [ __ ]
you didn't hit on the other girl she
said hey we should hang out sometime
okay she's giving you the green light
you know what i mean you're a guy you
have to take that
you got to take it women don't
understand that because they can get
laid every night of the [ __ ] week if
they want to they don't have to have any
game
and they it for us it's it's it's work
it's a skill okay so when somebody when
if it's like you're in the wild you got
a free [ __ ] meal you're gonna take it
you know i learned that in australia
when i was looking at those poisonous
snakes and like why does that thing have
enough venom
to kill 200 mice
why does it need that much venom it's
because it's out there in the [ __ ]
the outback and out in the outback food
is scarce
so if you get a shot at something you
got to [ __ ] take it down and that's
what the hell you did
yeah i'm a [ __ ] dog you know it's
like you know what [ __ ] you lady
i'm a dog then then you're a [ __ ]
if i'm a dog you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] did
i call you up
did i come around sniffing up your skirt
no you called me
because you wanted some dick and i gave
it to you how about a [ __ ] thank you
letter
dude you really should have come at her
like that you really should have and i
got to tell you something
on some [ __ ] up levels she would
actually respect you as long as you
didn't
don't call her a [ __ ] all right
but she [ __ ] she so what what is her
relationship with you
you guys barely talk and like whenever
she's in a dick dry spell
she [ __ ] goes over to you like your
hurts rent a car and just [ __ ]
just rides your dick and then you're
supposed to be exclusive
and not bang a friend who's cut from the
same cloth
who wants to get plowed before she goes
over to europe this is your [ __ ]
fault
you're the one who should feel used
you know neither one of them wants a
meaningful relationship with you
uh you know what this is what i say just
don't even write them back
and you know something [ __ ] them again
just bang them again you gives a [ __ ]
next time you see her she wants to give
you a dirty look just like
i i don't even react to it what what
what a [ __ ]
what a bunch of [ __ ]
and i got i can't believe that like you
we don't have a relationship
i'm just gonna keep saying the same
thing [ __ ] over and over again like
why don't i
let me i'm stuttering here
you know the other day i was watching
the uh when i was watching the texans
when the patriots played the texans
monday night football right
and uh some lady
at the at the at the was watching with
us
and she started giving bob craft [ __ ]
for having like uh a 35 year old
girlfriend
and for those who don't watch football
bob craft was married forever
had a family and his uh wife
unfortunately
uh died of cancer you know
so she dies at cancer you know he stuck
by her side did the whole damn thing
and then now he's got a new girlfriend
and she's 35 and women are mad they're
upset about they're upset by it and i i
don't uh
i don't get it you know
if i die of a disease i i don't want
[ __ ] near to be sitting here
like some spinster go on go have a good
time
i'm dead i don't give a [ __ ] you know
unless i'm a ghost and i'm sitting there
watching it then i wouldn't like it
[Laughter]
but i would just fly away why did i sit
there watching it
you know start haunting them every time
they were gonna have sex i wouldn't do
that to somebody
i just don't understand why like um it's
not like he went out and got with like a
18 19 20 21 year old girl she's 35
thirty-five at 35 if women aren't
married they're freaking out
right they look
i you know what i love i just love that
they get mad at the guy and it's like
what about the girl why is she with them
okay if he's some sort of like you know
oh he's just there
because he wants a hot girlfriend then
what about her she's just there for the
money so then it works out
doesn't it i don't know when whenever
like [ __ ] like that goes on that really
taps into the cynical part of me
which you know if you listen to this
podcast god knows it doesn't take much
but um
sometimes i just i just think that it
almost taps into that [ __ ] buddy thing
they just don't want to know how easily
that they could be replaced
yet they want you to feel
they don't give a [ __ ] if they if they
try and make you feel that way all those
stupid songs
beyonce that that to the left to the
left
you know that whole song is like yeah
just take your [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here i'll have another guy in two
seconds
you're that easily replaced
you know and they they love those songs
those songs are
they consider them [ __ ] empowering
but then when they see a successful guy
with a you know a nice closet full of
shiny ties and his own sports team
when they see that he can still [ __ ]
pull down some 35 year old ass
they get mad they start judging his
character
even me and my mom we had that
discussion i just don't think that
that's
i just i'm sure that there was somebody
in their
50s that he could have who the [ __ ]
wants to get with a 50 year old
even if you're 70.
you know
i don't [ __ ] you know what i mean you
know you're starting over again
if you got a [ __ ] old car and you
traded in
you don't trade it in on a [ __ ]
another old car you get a new one
you know you [ __ ] ride that thing
into the ground
and then you get another one i don't
know i'm just saying i don't have a
[ __ ] problem with what the guy's
doing
all right that's it all right everybody
if you like if you enjoyed this podcast
um and you'd like to support the podcast
and in a roundabout way support the
wounded warriors project go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
and click on
uh the amazon link if you're going to
buy anything on amazon not saying you
have to but if you got to buy something
just go and buy it doesn't change the
price but uh because you went through my
website they gave me a little kickback
and then i take a portion of those
proceeds
and i give it to the wounded warriors
project so everybody wins
you're helping out the podcast and more
importantly you're helping out the
troops
then that seems i'm kind of whoring out
their plight to increase
money that i'm making i don't know
there's something wrong about that whole
thing i don't know i'm doing a good
thing but this is just the way that
whole thing's set up but i i'm almost
doing like what the nfl's doing
with that pink [ __ ] you know what i mean
instead of telling people the foods that
they can eat to to knock down the
potential
of getting cancer they just have
everybody running around there dressed
like a barbie doll i don't get it
and i'm guessing somebody's making some
money off of it all right
that's all i'm saying um all right
that's the podcast for this week
everybody that's the
p a w d cast
that's the podcast for this week thank
you guys so much for listening
um nhl hockey i have given up on you
i've given up on you i've i've
threatened that i was gonna get the uh
whatever the [ __ ] the nba packages
and they had it for free for two three
days which was a great idea and i
watched it and i'm enjoying watching the
knicks
my celtics and watching the lakers lose
and i'm just well i guess i get the
lakers game out here all the time
you know bill russell wrote some book
basically describing
how he made the guys around him on his
team better
and i was reading this bill simmons
article it was making me sick to my
stomach because
i i couldn't finish reading it because i
think kobe is reading it
which would really be devastating
because i don't think kobe has ever
progressed
beyond where michael j michael jackson
michael jordan was
in about 1989 when michael was trying to
do it all himself
and there's nothing better as a celtics
fan
that when phil jackson isn't coaching
and kobe is just trying to do it all
himself
there's nothing [ __ ] better because
he's going to score 30 and they're going
to lose
and that's what i love seeing
[Laughter]
oh wouldn't that be ironic if it took a
celtic to teach a laker how to [ __ ]
win wouldn't that be something
all right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
you